ومريب الجيش العبري يخلي مجمع الشفاء في
ما تلبيب ترفض صفقه الاسرى واردوغان مع
اكثر من 2000 محامي لملاحقه تل ابيب
قضائيا وكارثه جديده في مدرسه بالقطاع تل
ابيب تقترض مليارات الدولارات لتمويل
حربها مجموعه السبع تفشل في التعامل مع
روسيا زيلينسكي يقيل رجل المخابرات الاول
في الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه الكرملن الغرب
يبني بعنايه شديده جسرا نحو المستقبل ل
النهائي الواضح مع موسكو القوات الجويه
الروسيه تطلق تحضيرها الاخير لبريطانيا
والمخابرات الامريكيه تكشف مخبا الدبابات
العربيه في اوكرانيا وفرقاه الروسيه تظهر
في دوله عربيه بشكل
مفاجئ تلبيب
ترفض هذه الحرب تتابع تسعها شيئا فشيئا لا
شيء يوقفها هنا اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ان تر ستبذل جهودا لاعاده
بناء البنيه التحتيه المدمره والمستشفيات
والمدارس في القطاع اذا تم التوصل الى وقف
اطلاق النار في القطاع مضيفا ان بلاده
ستتقدم مع اكثر من 2000 محام بشكوى الى
الجهات المعنيه ضد ما ارتكبته تلبيب في
القطاع حسب وكاله الاناضول التركيه فيما
وصلت الطائره الاغاثه السعوديه الحاد ع
الى مطار العريش الدولي في مصر تمهيدا
لنقلها الى المتضررين داخل القطاع وتزن خ
30 طنا وذلك ضمن الحمله الشعبيه لاغاثه
شعب القطاع من جانبها ابلغت تلبيب الوسطاء
القطريين انها ترفض تماما صفقه تبادل
الاسرى المحدثه مع الفصائل والتي تشمل
اطلاق صراح 50 رهينه عبريه محتجزين في
القطاع ميدانيا قال مصدر طبي في القطاع
انه جرى اخلاء مستشفى الشفاء من معظم
الاطباء والمرضى والنازحين لتعلن الامم
المتحده انها لا تستطيع حاليا ارسال
خبرائها الى مستشفى الشفاء في القطاع من
اجل تقييييم الوضع هناك فيما افادت شبكه
سي ان ان بانه من المحتمل ان يكون الجيش
العبري قد وضع او اعاد ترتيب الاسلحه في
مستشفى الشفاء في القطاع قبل وصول
الصحفيين الاجانب في سياق المعارك ايضا
اعلن المتحدث باسم الجيش العبري توسيع
العمليات الهجوميه في القطاع مشيرا الى
مداهمه منطقتي الزيتون وجبالي بهدف ضرب
المخربين والبنيه التحتيه للفصائل لتنقل
صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
توقعهم ان يستمر الزحف البري في القطاع
لثلاثه اشهر وان طال اكثر فسين هار
الاقتصاد وفق قولهم بينما كان قد سقط 200ي
شخص بين قتيل وجريح في قصف القوات العبريه
لمدرسه الفخوره التابعه للامم المتحده وهي
تاوي الاف النازحين في مخيم جباليه شمالي
القطاع هناك اعربت القاهره عن ادانتها
الشديده لقصف الجيش العبري المروع مدرسه
الفخوره التابعه للاونروا في انتهاك صارخ
جديد ضدهم في الجانب الاقتصادي اقترضت
تلبيب ست مليارات دولار مؤخرا عبر صفقات
تم التفاوض عليها سرا للمساعده في تمويل
حربها ضد الفصائل في القطاع لكنها اضطرت
الى دفع تكاليف اقتراض مرتفعه على نحو غير
عادي بحسب صحيفه فاينانشال
تايمز روسيا تطلق تحذيرها
الاخير حرب الغرب وروسيا تسير نحو طريق
واحد هنا اشارت بلومبرغ في تقرير لها الى
فشل قيود الغربيه المفروضه على صادرات
النفط الروسيه اذ يتم بيع برميل الخام
الروسي المنقول بحرا بسعر اعلى من السقف
السعري الذي حددته مجموعه جي س لتخرج
صحيفه و ستريت جورنال وتقول ان سياسه
روسيا الخارجيه وانجازاتها العسكريه
والاقتصاديه تثبت ان استراتيجيه الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين في مواجهه الغرب قد نجحت
واضافت الصحيفه في مقالتها لا يجوز ان
يكون اي من هذه الامور مفاجئا هناك اك اد
المتحدث باسم الكريملين ديمتري بيسكوف في
تعليقه على كلام المستشار الالماني اولاف
تشولز بشان حوار مستقبلي مع موسكو ان
الغرب يبني بعنايه شديده جسرا نحو
المستقبل النهائي الواضح واوضح بيسكوف
قائلا ان اللهجه في مثل هذه التصريحات
تغيرت بشكل كبير وقد كانوا في البدايه
يتحدثون عن هزيمه روسيا في اوكرانيا صرح
الجنرال اوكراني المتقاعد سيرغي كريفون
بانه لا يجب على اوكرانيا ان تجعل خساره
مدن جديده نتيجه للاعمال الهجوميه للقوات
الروسيه ماساه واكد ان الوضع في عده
قطاعات من الجبهه صعب بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه حيث يقوم الروس ببناء قوتهم
العسكريه وضرب القوات الاوكرانيه على وجه
الخصوص بالقرب من كوبيانسك في مقاطعه
خاركوف و مارينكا في جمهوريه دونيسك من
جهه اخرى اقال الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي نائب رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه الكسندر تاراسوف سكي
دون الكشف عن الاسباب باب لتفيد وكاله
بلومبرغ بان الولايات المتحده لن تتمكن من
تقديم مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا قبل
منتصف ديسمبر المقبل على الاقل او ربما
حتى ما بعد هذا الموعد هذا وذكرت صحيفه
نيويورك بوست في مقال مطول على ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن الاجابه عن سؤال عما
اذا كان الغرب سيرسل وحدات عسكريه كبيره
الى اوكرانيا برايكم هل يقدم بايدن على
خطوه كهذه فيما اعرب الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلنسكي عن مخاوفه من ان البلاد ربما
تستعد لميدان جديد يهدف لازاحته من السلطه
متهما روسيا بمحاوله تنفيذ انقلاب في
اوكرانيا في بريطانيا وصفت صحيفه اكسبريس
تحليق حامله الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه من
طراز 2 1660 والقا ظفه حامله الصواريخ
بعيده المدى تو 22 ام ثلاث الروسيه فوق
بحر النرويج بالتحضير لدوله بريطانيا وكان
نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي الكساندر فومان
قد قال ان انشطه بريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا
وهولندا وايطاليا تساهم في عسكره المنطقه
واثاره سباق التسلح في ميدان المعارك
الاوكرانيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسي ان
قواتها دمرت عددا من مستودعات الذخيره
والوقود للجيش الاوكراني فيما بلغت خسائر
العدو البشريه نحو 700 عسكري خلال يوم
واضافت الوزاره الروسيه ان الطيران البحري
الروسي دمر زوارق انزال سريع وسبعه زوارق
مسيره في البحر الاسود تابعه للبحريه
الاوكرانيه بينما افاد الضابط الم خبرات
العسكريه الامريكيه السابق سكوت ريتر بان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحتفظ بالدبابات
الغربيه في الاحتياط خوفا من تدميرها على
يد الجيش الروسي وتابع ريتير في هذا الطقس
سوف تعلق الدبابات على الفور في الوحل
وسترسل لاندسات و تدمرهم ولا نريد ان نرى
دبابه امريكيه تحترق بعيدا عن اوكرانيا
افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان فرقاته
تابعه للبحريه الروسيه قامت بزياره عمل
الى الجزائر فيط رحلتها في البحر الابيض
المتوسط هناك شاركت قياده الفرقه في
اجتماعات بروتوكول مع قياده المنطقه
البحريه التابعه للقوات البحريه الجزائريه
ومع القاعده البحريه الجزائريه واداره
الميناء